Darhk, Merlyn and the Speedster. The Legion of Doom.
I'm not calling them that
We're on sort of a time clock here
the Legion have nothing
they have Rip
please let me go!
who do we kill first?!
these guys are good!
DC's Legends of Tomorrow, all new episodes return January 24th
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
Everybody bow down to the new god of the DC
universe.
The reverse flash with the Spear of destiny.
So I'll explain what's going on is a bunch
of other footage and here for the next episode
the flash ring giveaway is also still going
on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything during the break.
So let's address the rip hunter footage in
this first because the whole thing is about
the Legion taking control of rip hunter is
really only one reason why they would need
to do that if they needed him to get one step
closer to finding the Spear of destiny.
They assemble the artifacts they have sort
of like a star chart, map, but that might
not lead them directly to the Spear of destiny
that might just be like the next step on their
path to obtaining it.
So the only reason for them to really go after
rip hunter is if rip hunter knows where it
is or has the information that will get them.
One step closer the episode that most of this
footage is from is called Raiders of the lost
art as an Raiders of the lost Ark so that
just implies that there's a piece of artwork
somewhere in history that tells them where
to find the Spear of destiny.
So the Legion needs to find the artwork they
need to get rip hunter to find out where that
is, but the Post credits scene from the last
episode was rip hunter in this like 70s get
up with giant sideburns directing this movie
based on the plot of legends of tomorrow is
can we try this right people want to be here
all night to myself, so it seems like rip
hunter knew that this was all going to happen.
The Legion was going to come after him was
a defense mechanism he wiped his mind to a
certain extent.
So part of the comedy of this is them just
running into him, hey rip we haven't seen
you in a while and him just being like I have
Apsley no idea what's going on and I'm speaking
with an American accent so we don't really
know how many episodes rip is going to be
in in the back half of the season or how is
going to figure into the Spear of destiny
plot because that is the key to the reverse
flash gains the powers of God and the ability
to rewrite reality and that's what this is
all about this whole season is about the reverse
flash getting the Spear of destiny.
So that he can a race Barry Allen from existence
without erasing himself is the only way around
the problem that he can find the future flash
message that they reference on legends will
probably figure into this is well.
As this avatar plot two, so the really tying
the shows together in a really big way even
though their main plot seem like there separate
called the choice you know you also supposed
changes affect the present to compound in
the future when you return you in the new
time.
Once future, including yours trust anything
more.
So even if you haven't read the comics you
don't know a lot about you bar Thawne the
reason he can't kill Barry Allen is because
the speed force comes from Barry Allen he
generates it when he runs he is like the source
of the speed force in all of the multi-verse
on all the planets in all of the universes.
So if the reverse flash kills Barry Allen
it means the speed force won't come into existence.
So with the reverse flash kills Barry Allen.
It effectively kills his own future, so he
needs to find a way to a race Barry Allen
without erasing the things that come with
Barry Allen, namely the speed force.
The only way to do that is to rewrite reality
in the only way to do that is to gain the
powers of a God via the Spear of destiny.
What is the most effective way to use the
Spear to we have to talk about this wielding
the Spear.
There a lot of different ways they could do
this on the TV show, but the most amazing
way for him to do that would be to just run
Barry through with the spear like literally
impale him on the Spear of destiny.
So in gaining the powers of the spear the
reverse flash gains the power to rewrite reality
becomes a God in his own right, which is funny
because we have a God of speed on the flash
right now savitar, but remember he only calls
himself a God your smart about before you
are knowingly that was such a great quote.
The way they wrote it, you don't need something
to absolutely be true.
You seem to get enough people to believe it's
true.
To make it true that were talking about reverse
flash Spear of destiny that's literal God
like you actually have the powers of God.
So what about the rest of the Legion of doom
in the rest of this footage there like a couple
of the things that you may have spotted in
here one is vixen in bed with citizen steel,
which is weird because she had a thing going
on with his grandfather commander steel, so
they just got real weird real fast.
Plus she also has all that chemistry with
heatwave no idea where that's going and then
there are the colonial soldiers where we also
saw a rip hunter pop up so big twist might
be that there are different aspects of rip
hunter splintered across time and they have
to combine them all to get back to regular
rip hunter.
If you remember marvels time runs out storyline
that led into secret wars molecule man is
somebody that exists in multiple realities
at the same time so they might've done that
same thing with rip hunter where you have
many different aspects of rip hunter just
splintered across time is a defense mechanism
for preventing the reverse flash from getting
the Spear of destiny.
So that might be what they're doing in the
back half like will have to go around and
collect all these rip Hunter's.
So the other big thing there's like so much
stuff that's happening with legends of tomorrow
they're moving it to Tuesday nights after
the flash like the flash is on at 8 PM on
Tuesday nights, at least in the United States
right after that will be legends of tomorrow
so I don't know if it's gonna be the same
thing in other countries you have to check
your listings the schedule change might just
be for North America.
So just be sure to check your TV schedules
for that last week in January to January 24
when it's coming back.
So, that's also the day that the flash is
coming back to will be flash then legends
of tomorrow and then Arrow is still on Wednesdays,
the same time.
So I'm going to have to figure out what the
new video schedules going to be but we have
a couple weeks to figure it out.
So it's not a big deal I'll remind everyone
about the change will make a little bit closer.
But again it's not coming for at least another
four or five weeks.
So it's not a huge deal right now but let
me know in the comments what you think is
going to happen when the reverse flash inevitably
gets his hands on the Spear of destiny something
is going to have to happen to get it out of
his hands because you just like Sandoz assembling
the infinity gauntlet in Avengers infinity
war you want to see that moment where the
villain stands triumphant becomes a God in
his own right, and then the real fun after
that is watching how the heroes fix that in
whether or not it's going to involve other
versions of the flash or is just gonna be
the legends and what the hell is Sara gonna
do when she finds out that Laurel is back,
seemingly somebody who doesn't know what's
been happening for the last couple of months.
The way they set it up in the arrow trailer
is that she doesn't know anything after she
died last season so it's almost like the version
were getting is the version that died she
just coming back.
But because she's been in the ground for a
couple months.
She hasn't been around for all this craziness,
so because it's the holiday weekend is gonna
be a whole bunch more comic book stuff dropping
so keep her eyes peeled for Justice league
trailer if there any bonus videos you guys
want specifically this weekend.
Just let me know in the comments.
But I'm in be doing some best of Christmas
themed comic book videos from Marvel and DC
like Spider-Man saves Christmas the flash
saves Christmas there's a whole bunch of really
awesome holiday, comic book story while you
guys wait for that to post you can click here
for the flash trailer for the next episode
and you can click here for the arrow trailer
that you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!